From "Young Leonard" to a show about
Penny's journey as a new mother,
fans of The Big Bang Theory
have all kinds of ideas about
what the upcoming spin-off should be
about. Here's what they're saying.
The Big Bang Theory is returning to television...
kind of. According to The Hollywood Reporter,
during a press event for tons of
different Warner Bros. properties,
it was announced that Max — the streamer formerly
known as HBO Max — will be home to a brand new Big
Bang Theory spin-off. Chuck Lorre, who created
the original for CBS alongside Bill Prady,
will also be involved. Max has been the
exclusive streaming home of The Big Bang
Theory for a while now, so this doesn't
come as a shock. Whether or not there's
more ground to cover in the Big Bang Theory
Cinematic Universe is a question, though.
"Oh good, they used my NASA picture."
Whatever this show will cover is up in the
air, and Lorre and his team are remaining
tight-lipped — but back in 2019, he did tell
The Hollywood Reporter he was open to spin-offs:
"Truthfully, the reason for a spinoff is
economics, and that's not the reason to do a show.
You should do a show because you have something
you really love and you want to do it. Economics
follow passion. If you start with economics
... well, s--t, become a network executive."
Obviously, there's already one Big Bang
spin-off, which is the apparent result
of Chuck Lorre walking into the main CBS
office and simply pitching "what if Sheldon,
but young?" Since 2017, Young Sheldon
has been an enormous hit for the network,
and now, Max will have their own
potential Lorre hit on their hands.
There's any range of things this
spin-off could focus on — perhaps
a younger version of a different
character, like Howard Wolowitz
in college? Lorre did rule out a spin-off
of Leonard and Penny Hofstadter's journey
into parenthood after Penny discovered
she was pregnant in the series finale.
"My head is wrapped."
"Well, if something else was wrapped
we wouldn't be in this situation."
Back in 2019, Lorre told The Hollywood Reporter,
"No. [...] I feel like these seven characters
share seven different areas of the same brain.
We have split them off in every single different
division you can and it all works. There's no two
that don't work together. I don't think it would
be a disaster, but it wouldn't be Big Bang."
Considering how out-of-the-blue news of yet
another Big Bang Theory show was, it only
makes sense that it has elicited strong reactions.
Folks have rushed to social media to share their
feelings on the impending spin-off and suffice
to say, the online masses have mixed feelings.
One person wrote on Twitter:
"I love this show, but like [...] Why?"
"And it's done." " Yup we're all in." "Alright
I'll see you guys in 20 years."
And this person isn't the only one asking that
question. Numerous people are questioning why
there needs to be another entry in the Big
Bang Theory franchise. Another fan wrote
on Twitter that they are more than happy with
leaving the franchise behind once Young Sheldon
concludes. Meanwhile, one Twitter user, among many
others, can't hide their disappointment over the
seemingly endless stream of sequels, prequels, and
reboots that plague modern Hollywood as a whole.
"I knew it!"
At the same time, there are quite a few people
who've voiced their support for the new show.
For example, a Big Bang fan wrote on Twitter
that they're hopeful that the series could
follow Penny's younger years with Katey Sagal
back as her mother. Another Twitter user came
up with a pitch of their own for a program
dedicated to Penny's goofy ex, Zack Johnson.
"How can you bounce stuff off
the moon if there's no gravity?"
Meanwhile, another person wrote on
the social media site that the new
Big Bang spin-off is coming together
in response to the success of Young
Sheldon — so they tossed out the idea of
having it focus on Leonard's childhood.